our first guest on our final day of week
in the super bowl that we will never
forget super bowl 56 week here in los
angeles california the head coach of the
washington commanders
and also one of the few guys who's ever
coached in the super bowl and also won
one ron rivera good to see you coach
thank you it's good to be a rich thank
you you got the w
commander's jacket on huh yeah we got
the swag you know it's a kind of a neat
deal when i put it on for the first time
i kind of had a flashback back to high
school
it does look like a letterman jacket
that you've got on yeah they did a nice
job and you know the really cool thing
also they have the logo on the back uh
the the um the shield it's kind of a
neat deal that they did some really nice
things well you can't be a team in the
mid-atlantic without a shield you know
what i mean like everybody that's that's
kind of like a maryland thing right oh
very much so very much so it's kind of
cool though it really is okay fantastic
well congrats on on the name change and
and all of that um when you think of the
super bowl what what memories oh wow
right off the bat i go back to super
bowl uh for the 1985 super bowl bears i
really do i go back and i think about
all those guys i think about coach ditka
and just the team and and and the city
of chicago did you do the shuffle no no
how how did you vera missed the super
bowl
i hear that a lot here now here here's
here's what happened yes
so
it was a it was the monday night game
against miami the only game we lost
we we go to the airport it's like two
o'clock in the morning we're flying back
after it after your first loss after our
first loss our only loss i guess and
willie goff's going through the plane
telling everybody hey we're going to do
this video it's for charity it's you
know it's going to be going to be called
the super bowl shuffle
and there's a group of us going dude
come on now we just got beat we're going
to land at
5 30 in the morning and we got to go
straight downtown to a studio
so if you really look at the super bowl
shuffle there were several guys that had
to be blue screened in i mean walter
payton was mike singletary was jim
mcmahon william perry um not everybody
you know went that day anyways and so a
group of us aren't in it and and so just
because of the fact that it happened
right after we lost so if you had won
that monday night oh we'd all been there
oh yeah without a doubt okay without a
doubt in my mind and so
what you're saying is because it was off
of a loss
a late night flight and a quick
turnaround in an early morning
so when i was looking at their dancing
and i thought it looks like they're
sleepwalking
they literally literally were still
asleep because okay because i thought
the dancing was always terrible but they
were half asleep yeah
i had no idea yeah okay and so still
you wouldn't get green screened in or
blue screened in right now uh i wasn't i
wasn't at that level yet what do you
mean well you know there's some very
special guys they green screen didn't
you know guys that really truly if you
look at them i mean just you know the
iconic guys you know uh william perry
jim mcmahon walter payton mike singleton
i mean just guys that you know that that
were
well you know they were a-list guys
right so winning that um winning that
super bowl um and uh we all know that
buddy got carried off did dicker really
get pissed off about that no i don't
think so i think in the moment i think
we really were i mean it was it was such
a
celebration right that you really you
know you're just happy for everybody you
really were okay and then uh fred
scoring that touchdown what was that
like when it was after he was he was
kind of cool you know it was and and and
it's funny though because if you ask
coach sticker today
his biggest regret was that walter
didn't score right yeah did anybody
realize that at the time no i don't
think anybody realized it and that's and
that was unfortunate because you know
for all the greatness and everything
that that walter had that's the one
thing that i i think you know he thinks
about yeah and i just uh were you at nfl
honors last night did you go no no
unfortunately i bet i bet because you
you probably have to take particular
good care of yourself right around
i was honestly i was in bed by 8 30.
okay so
to me again um the fact that the last
award at nfl honors is the walter payton
man of the year award
it's just a it's it's a beautiful moment
every single year
what memory of sweetness
do you have that might um
you know tie this maybe a little bit
together here right um
really was was the way he treated people
and i will never forget the day he met
my mother and father we were playing
dallas in dallas it's the game we beat
him forty four were sure were you
over your right shoulder
it was it was it was the super bowl year
was 85 we were playing in dallas one of
the things that i had got written into
my contract was that that the team would
fly my parents to an away game and treat
them you know
like kings i mean kings and queens i
mean they put them up in the hotel they
paid for all their meals they paid for
their tickets
walter just happened to be walking by
when i when i when i greeted my parents
and he came over introduced him he gave
my mom a hug and they turned my dad says
gino let's go buy a beer so he took my
dad and got him a beer in the bar and
and and just the way he it was like he
knew them forever
and that to me is the essence of the the
walter payton man of the year is that
you treat everybody special
and and so when
you know i had one of my players thomas
davis wanted and and and that day it's
one of those things that that i was so
proud of thomas because i knew who
walter was and and thomas epitomized
walter in my opinion so yeah because
it's one thing to just say hi nice to
meet you maybe you know obviously there
were camera phones back in that day yeah
but you know take a picture if you if
but then to say hey let's go
grab a beer and then several years later
when i was working with the national
hispanic scholarship foundation
we did the uh we did the culmination
tournament in puerto rico and walter
came with us down there and my father
being a puerto rican descent he i flew
my father out for the event he saw my
dad said you know let's go get a beer
and that's what they did they went in
and got a [ __ ] so now it started a
tradition yeah so you know anytime they
you know it was i told my dad says you
know
just so you know walter doesn't always
drink beer all the time dad
you know but but it was kind of cool
because because he got to tell his
brothers you know and porter but hey you
know walter payton bought me a beer
yeah i saw his son last night too oh
what a good dude good young man you know
and it just means so much and then you
know for whitworth now
to play the super bowl with that patch
on his yeah because that patches that
patch means a lot to a lot of it really
does it honestly truly does and and and
i think it's it's something that the
league really likes to point to because
it really does show that there are guys
that are truly committed to giving back
to their communities and and we should
because you know they support us they
buy the tickets they buy the merchandise
they cheer for us boo us on occasion but
for the truth of the matter is we should
we should also give back and and so to
see the players do these things that
they're doing today i think it's great i
really do washington commanders head
coach ron rivera here on the rich
housing show i got to get used to saying
that i do too
i'm used to hearing it right so um
is the quarterback of the 2022
commanders on your roster well that's
part of what we're working through you
know can the guys that we have on the
roster ascend to be that kind of guy um
you know is that guy out there in the
draft is he in free agency is can we
make a trade for a guy those are the
things that we're working through right
now and and i know this because you know
martin mayhew marty herney those guys
they're working on these things right
now and and when we get back that'll be
one of the topics of conversation as we
prepare for the combine so um you're are
you already grinding tape on kids at the
at the college level getting some
footage back from the senior bowl things
like that yes we have um okay you know
we
we we were at every we were represented
at every one of these uh these these
bowl games these these college bowl
games we had guys watching
particularly the quarterback position
and and really working through these
things um and like i said you know we're
not going to just stop on the college
level we're going to look at the free
agents we're going to look and see what
else is out there for us okay and so uh
what what do you do now um in this off
season at the combine and things of that
nature walk me through what your role
is as the the hc of the i guess the wc
here yeah
the biggest thing we do more so anything
else that i think is one of the most
important things is when you get an
opportunity to interview the players you
know we we interview them a little
differently i think than some of the
teams what do you mean well one of the
things we like to do is we like to
incorporate tape
we we we want to hear them talk about
what's on tape
you know we try to gauge as much as we
can showing them their plays probably
the last year or how far back do you
even go without we'll go to last year
well
you know it's not all good
we're looking for things we're listening
for certain answers um and and so as we
go through that process that helps us it
really does and then you know once we
decide which guys we want to bring in
we'll do the same thing when we when we
have we're allowed to have the visits
right hopefully we'll have allowed to
have the business in person i i'd much
rather visit in person and if we can fly
guys into our city and give them an
opportunity to sit down and talk to them
and listen to them and then show tape
and go through that as well you know
because you really can't prepare for all
the tape they can they can prepare for
the q a
okay they can rehearse all that but they
can't
look at all their tape and and be able
to answer all those questions you have a
good you have a good example of maybe
someone you drafted anywhere that you've
done this with that oh we did it with
what the answer from the tape was just
like okay yeah we did it we did we did
it with cam newton and and and and
because when i was in carolina and he
was our first pick yeah um and we sat
down and we showed you know the
highlights obviously but then we saw
some of the low lights and one of the
things that i always appreciated about
cam was he took responsibility right off
the bat
and as soon as the play came on he put
that big smile on he said oh that was my
fault
and i'm watching tape and i kept
thinking myself i don't know if that was
your fault because i thought that
receiver could have pushed that a little
bit higher
but he had thrown it it was one of the
few interceptions he threw that year but
he just had that smile and took that
responsibility and he said yeah i could
have put that out in front of them a
little bit more
you know so when when you get guys that
want to take responsibility when you
guys that want to take it take the
pressure off their teammates that's an
important thing that really is but right
away he he looked at the table said oh
you know what they came out they were in
cover too and i threw that ball out over
there and the corner was able to work
underneath it you know and used it i'm
sitting there thinking yeah but that guy
could have pushed it instead of running
a flatter you know 70 should have taken
higher
and so you you get that sense that that
he understood he knew
at the same time though he didn't want
to put it on his guy he took he took the
he took the hit and and so i i that was
impressive to me ron rivera here on the
rich eisen show and that was the
previous to this weekend only matchup
between two first overall drafted
quarterbacks faces governor in the super
bowl with super bowl
50 how do you see this one playing out
this weekend you know to me it it it's
going to be if one of two things
happened you know
watching this year's playoffs which i
thought were phenomenal some great games
the one thing that that cincinnati did
struggle with was protecting the
quarterback right and with this pass
rush the rams have
that could make an immediate impact in
the game but if they can protect the
quarterback they can run the ball
early on i think cincinnati can slow
that pass rush down a little bit that'll
work to their benefit so it's one of two
things if the pass rush is working for
the rams that could be pretty deadly
on the inverse if they can run the ball
early on and set the tone in tempo and
take the pressure off of joe burr early
i think it could be it could go
cincinnati's way so now you know
obviously you didn't have a shot at
borough but you uh you evaluate
everybody yeah so what was your
evaluation to borrow coming out of
college we really liked him a lot we we
believed he had he had the mental
ability to to learn graphs understand
right away um and he had he had the
skill set i mean you know
you could tell that on tape
didn't know he'd be there in his second
year but you know we felt he was a guy
that had that type of of ability had the
types of quality that you're looking for
in in the quarterback would mcmahon have
did he smoke cigars too did jim smokes a
guard
his ice and stuff like that or what he's
doing right now he did um you know jimmy
mack was special he really was a
tremendous leader the guy that you would
want on your team because he he's that
kind of guy he's a foxhole guy you know
you want him in that foxhole with you
because jimmy mack was a guy that was
going to find a way to win and and and
he was really one of those guys that
that i i think was was the epitome of of
of team guy because he did a lot of
things for us
and really helped us get to where we
wanted to be did you see the headband
the day he wrote rozelle on it before he
put it on did you see it oh yeah in the
locker room he had a he had a few of
them he was going to wear
what do you mean he had a few of them he
had you know remember he had a couple of
messages he had the one for for for his
teammate and and and that he put on as
well so you know he he he jimmy mack is
was was was a guy that loved having a
good time he always had fun he really
did and um that was one of the cool
things about it you know when when
things were tough when when i remember
one time in in training camp that was a
hot day it was a brutal day and it was
it was you know we had had like four or
five straight days of double days in
pads
uh that's a thing of the past you know
yes indeed um so
it was about after the fourth one and it
was it was a hot afternoon and and so
we're kind of going through it and coach
was honest dicka was getting after us
pretty good
and jimmy mack yelled out hey
iron what the heck why are you getting
on the guys man it's a brutal day says
oh yeah what do you think i think you
got to let us go in
take the take the afternoon off and so
then dick just turned around said all
right guys take it in
he said but don't be late for these
meetings or i'll get after you
and that's kind of how jimmy he would
stick up for us and it was just one of
those things he felt now as a coach i
wonder if they didn't set that up where
you know i mean
what do you mean what do you mean you
know every now and then you have one of
your guys step up and that way you know
he's your leader and uh
but
uh yeah come on oh look
that's some next level um you know stuff
right
yeah a little mental warfare so now you
say as a coach so is on occasion
this has happened for for you or you
walk up to your guy i won't say that
directly
i don't want you to give up your your
the trick of your trades yeah okay but
you know but but but again seriously
though the one thing about jimmy was
jim mcmahon was to me the the ultimate
teammate
um before i let you go i do want you to
ask the question about you know you are
the coach
everything that's going on with your
organization how do you parse all this
out i mean what do you how do you handle
all this well the the biggest thing most
anything else is that to me when
everything comes down to football
everything comes down to football and
and and and all the other stuff that's
not football
specific
you know i i kind of categorize as
that's interesting for us as football
okay the other stuff that that that when
i step away from football then you know
that to me is then it becomes important
it becomes something i need to handle i
need to take care of but the football
stuff i try to say focus on i try to get
the players to understand you know
what's important and what's interesting
and if we can keep the focus on the
things that we need to compartmentalize
separate uh it gives us a chance to be
able to focus in on playing coach
appreciate you coming here um before
before i forget okay what do you got is
that a bag
back okay let me see this hold on very
good thank you oh very good it's a swag
bag yeah
uh all right washington it says
washington football team okay that's all
it's not no but here we go here comes
here comes the big here
this is the big moment there you go the
commander
very nice okay all right i got that
look are you guys it's a pretty sweet
hat look at this chris look at that
right there you know that that looks so
that looks so good i mean if you put
that over the top of that star back
there oh yeah well now tj
sit down for a second tj would you
please you got this hat has tj ever
giving you anything with a star he has
never given me anything with a star on
it i now have gotten something with a w
on
you can talk to him i don't know if you
see that velvet rope that's in between
those bags over your right shoulder you
see what that is oh yeah that is uh
because there's been a lot of cowboy
hating on his way
on this show
he has a tier system as to who he
allows to talk to him
that's why he hasn't answered
wow
you're allowed to talk to him
if you have three or more wins in the
super bowl let's talk you're in the vip
one to two wins you're in the club so
congratulations coach ron rivera had no
idea coming here to the rich eisen show
today you're in the club okay you know
you guys had you somehow unfortunately
lost super bowl 20. you'd have to wait
in line wow well also rich like coach
washington football team they do have
three
commanders commanders i'm sorry
commanders i'm sorry uh they do have
three super bowl ones so they're in vip
oh and ron personally has one so that's
so coach
i appreciate that i really do thank you
now you may go forth into your friday
sir thanks for coming with all the swag
i always appreciate you calling and of
course you and your wife your lovely
wife uh helping with um
uh
children's
hospital and your run um i'm gonna do it
again in about two months time you know
we'll be there to support you i really
appreciate that you and your dog too i
hope as well so thank you honestly the
videos you put out there and what you've
done and financially supporting it there
we go right here okay we got it up right
here who's who's your what's
oh he loves everything about baltimore
there it goes tahoe wow yeah that can't
help himself that ain't happening for me
but maybe
should somebody roll a ball out maybe
i'll run faster
no tahoe if tahoe runs with me it'll be
just like those samuel camps where
somebody's right off the screen and i'm
barely out of my stance
thanks for coming on coach thank you yes
indeed thank you that's uh ron rivera
right here at riverboat ron hc on
twitter and instagram hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here